XANA next one I told you it's it's
called what happened miss Simone yeah
yeah I Nina Simone check out that reel
that a man see amazing songs do amazing
songs amazing music should like Sharla
Minah to God Oh Charlotte all due
respect all the respect cuz the music is
amazing oh all those eggs music is
amazing but it was you know it was a
different time
that was a different time is a different
it was a different time you know I mean
it was a different you just listening to
music ain't no music videos that's the
thing we don't want you to hear these
fat [ __ ] talking about how hard it is
to be fat and be a musician
there was a [ __ ] making music way
before you know these fat [ __ ] what's
that fat [ __ ] name which one is yeah
the singing [ __ ] I doubt the black
Adele Liz Oh Liz oh oh I know but like
we don't need to hear how hard it is for
you there have been ugly people making
music for years it's weird why don't we
hear how hard it is for you and then
everybody celebrates you for being fat I
feel like you got to pick one at this
point pick one side they're hard to be
fat or we all celebrate a view if it's
hard to be fat we could judge you for
being fat and that proves that it's hard
to be fun boom but if there's not it was
hard and now it's great so you know it's
cool that's great pick a side
celebrate it and you're good hmm
unbelievable this [ __ ] of course you
would try to have her cake and eat it
too [ __ ] what is it about like what is
it about that is annoying is that it is
it like your is your
literally trying to have your cake and
eat it too is like you're trying to be a
victim and you're using the victimhood
to be selling I think that's what basis
yeah I think that's what bothers one of
the other for us everybody jump on board
and be like oh so amazing I miss her I
love her no you don't like you don't
have to do this they're only doing it so
that they can look progressive they can
look progressive it's the same [ __ ]
where Howard Stern said gab Gabrielle
Sidibe precious he was like she needs to
lose weight everybody celebrating her
being like big like this she's not gonna
have the career shoe to have a shoes 200
pound skinnier yeah from what I
understand it's basically what he said
and everybody jumped on his down his
throat and [ __ ] Howard Stern she's been
in how many movies since a couple Tower
Heist or whatever with Eddie Murphy and
Ben Stiller probably one or two others I
can't think of that's yeah that's cuz
all the fat [ __ ] and movies are
played by black men Barrymore Lawrence
if you need a fat [ __ ] movie bro male
black actor is gonna take that role in
the fat [ __ ] unless movies in Tyler
Perry Murphy Eddie Murphy Oh Norbit
no sir nutty perfect son that black
[ __ ] can't get no roles out here and
they got all the roles maybe wasn't that
point yeah did you think Eddie Murphy
took more jobs from black actors in
Hollywood you played eight black people
no it's like he made Chappelle famous he
made Rock famous he's like I gotta cut
this [ __ ] out it might not be an AE
Murphy no more he started playing all
the roles son the same thing with Robin
Williams Robin Williams with voice all
the characters in the cartoons with a
ladder issues like him [ __ ] get
some work out here Robin you steal
people's jokes and their role dude
that's a great [ __ ] point yeah they
probably took him out yo yo yo steel
jobs from white people so I come out and
brag about it bro his name was Robin bro
holy [ __ ] now we'll alter do you think
that's why they do the training
Eddie oh that's why here Oh No that's
why he had to start doing his own roles
as he was putting too many black people
on put Rocko push a pail on put Martin
on you know what now let's get this guy
out of here mm-hmm
oh no uh-uh I think it's the other way I
think the black actors like waving he's
doing all the characters in the movies
and our roles aren't there no more we
got to get him out of here go get a
medic inspire yo come on mine are you
Mikey my game kale turret what whatever
you got possessed by Kim Jong I don't
know dude that'd be crazy but we're in
all seriousness what we're just saying
remember Oh auntie workers training oh
yeah do you think that's a possibility
Oh black people conspiring to come
together do black people conspire to
come together
Alki says no I don't know I haven't been
I haven't been brought in
you haven't been brought in to the
meetings yeah oh maybe the goat bro the
clip-on mug shot which clip is the
question oh my he is the funniest
[ __ ] on intentionally funny he's
the most unintentionally funny human
being that I've ever seen in my entire
life there's a clip I got this [ __ ] on
my phone yeah there's a clip of him
giving these conferences he does these
gives these conferences where he
basically just takes advantage of a very
uh black people it means really sad man
and like bad guys I like a lot of things
he says but you don't though
that's the thing like if you listen to
him you don't yeah you know okay maybe I
haven't listened enough I don't know as
I say I don't have a real opinion one
way or the other and what I've heard I
heard a little snip isn't like high
school no that's the thing broken clock
right toe two times a day right so like
he's perfect ample of that like he'll
say some [ __ ] that's like empowering as
much
I don't even wanna like get into like do
you know which which conference no I got
I got to clip somewhere right here man
cuz I've laughed at this I got it y'all
ready yeah y'all ready for this [ __ ]
yeah all right so I give you a long
version short for analysis longer 44
seconds okay should I send it to you can
you explain who he is yeah so one guy
mark don't know about I'm sending it to
your phone out yeah
so dr. Umar Johnson is the the Prince of
pan-africanism pan-africanism I guess
which is a movement it's a black
empowerment movement and he's a very
strict racial opinions about how black
people should operate and you're right
there are there is some black pride
baked in there and about like
togetherness and health and support and
community etc but um and I got a lot of
[ __ ] about this a few years ago but the
cool thing about the truth is that it
never ages guys truth never ages hmm I
call it harm
never a truth so basically he had this
hustle back in the day like I I picked
up at he was a con artist and she liked
that but this was he was gaining a lot
of steam back then he want to like start
this like charter school for like black
boys and he was like getting all these
like donations and to start it and they
never ended up becoming a school and it
looked like a whole scam and who knows
what he's trying to do but I basically
called mouths like dude he's got like a
lot of like super racist and homophobic
rhetoric and it's like stupid this is
back I'm really natus when I was like
trying to like make like such title
points about [ __ ] everybody called me
[ __ ] alright or racist this that the
other and a few years later now he's
just a laughingstock in the internet but
that's fine no apologies necessary guys
it's okay justice for my character but
that's fine okay so here it's like but I
absolutely love this guy he's [ __ ]
hilarious I mean I don't love him in
terms of anything he says laugh at him
oh my god he is so fun again you know I
do vol post like retards on his
Instagram and there
this is my version of that okay so play
this this is him at a conference is it a
common talk about how to fix a community
and okay normally anger in pain and once
they see I scare them then we can have a
conversation and fellas I want to be
clear now when we go back to take over
the community because we won't have to
do it gentlemen you can't expect the
cops to fix this because they started it
but I want to be clear and know some of
us love our children but some of our
children are so far gone that we would
have to put some of them to sleep in
order to take back the neighborhood some
of y'all don't want to hear that because
you don't live in reality when I'm
telling you as a psychologist I'm not
gonna be with psychologize some of them
are going to sleep for literally a week
straight maybe a week straight every day
I said Charlemagne hilarious what a
Charla say cuz Charlotte I was Charlotte
put him on breakfast club a lot oh I
think Charlotte is entertained by I
honestly don't know cuz I asked him I
was like I don't get it like you know
he's not a doctor right cuz I started
looking into [ __ ] his name was dr.
Wilmer Johnson I'm starting to look I
was like where's he a doctor from like
where'd he get his degree yeah and I was
like just ask if he's a doctor like I
can't find I googled it I cannot find
any degree for being doctor that's first
step of Connor's but the bare minimum
you're kind of you can't find it so I'm
like oh the whole thing is fraud Wow
yeah Wow yeah bro that's the thing he
already put a lot of you sleep
[Applause]